good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials good morning
Millennials mornin what's doing morning
ones how are you I'm good I feel like
one I haven't seen you and actually I
saw you two days ago but briefly when I
was at your house oh yeah my pictures of
Theo when I caught you stealing that was
so weird I came home and she was just
like rifling through my drawers I'm like
what are you doing here why
but if anything I brought you gifts I
brought you a cheese string which for
Aikido man you didn't have any in your
apartment it's funny I buy so much
cheese and then when Claudia goes into
the fridge and like sees cheese I guess
she assumes that it's been there for
like two weeks so she just throws it all
away and then we have a conversation I'm
like actually caught I just bought a
hundred hours in Babybel yesterday and
now it's all gone also like processed
cheese doesn't go bad because it's
project process and fresh cheese doesn't
go bad because you it gets better with
age it depends now mozzarella no but
like cheese sharings literally you
should take them into the bunker like
they never know bad ever as long as it's
cold it's good it can be warm and then
cold they feel good yes but a warm
cheese string oh my god where it's like
slap in our nose really mastered how
sceeto you're looking good
you like impossible today Cheetos great
oh my god I do look like intox help me
beat me if you want to reach me I look
like Rufus you look like Rufus actually
you look like Kim no no you look like
him I look like Shido who's like her
evil alter ego yes good stuff I almost
so they're doing the Kim Possible
live-action movie and like when times
were good I almost got an audition for
sheet oh they were interested in me Wow
right because they like I wanted to be
Kim obviously and that everyone wanted
that for me but they really wanted like
a high-school-aged person they didn't
want to be like Hollywood 25 year old
playing someone in high school oh no I
don't want that right and all of a
sudden they don't want that when it
comes to me and I'm actually the only 25
year old who looks like they're in high
school no no it's also like that is
Hollywood no totally remember Jackson
from Hannah Montana was 45 totally
but they decided to change it just when
it applied to me but they were
interested in
for Shido but then they weren't Wow but
I know I don't have an acting bone in my
body except for Homer don't worry you
guys I would crush it you would anyway
so little Kim and Chico action today
you're looking slim and trim thank you I
think I'm gonna launch a series of Kido
season merch what do you think about
that okay hats that you say Kido season
I'm trying to brand Kido season as just
good vibes it's not only like when you
eat something it's keto season but like
oh that good thing happened to you
that's keto season because keto is good
okay okay or it's like oh I'm looking
good in this picture that's ketosis
because of keto season no it's just in
general like keto equals good things so
keto season is a life of good or the
next one hashtag kita season you know
okay maybe it needs a little finessing I
understand but I see what you're trying
to do I think I would wear a hat that
said keto season I would definitely
support you like whatever hat you come
out but when I was at Serafina the other
night and I was my table was quito
season like it was just a natural
reaction to be like quito season you
know seasons ingrained in your brain and
it's like you need to take a video of
your food now because you will find out
retro actively whether or not you ate a
hair yes every single time I post a
picture of any kind of sushi they're
like I hope it's not Nobu no we are
never eating at Nobu again because I
found a hair
I actually went I was traumatized but I
did happen to go to Nobu because it was
the only restaurant open and in the area
where we were after Olivia's engagement
party and it was very good like usually
it's not great
no no usually it's worse like it was
better I feel like they might know about
Harrogate and they they're trying
I understand to step up their game but
it's never been great depends which
location you go to I think that it's
never great I think there's always
better I think certain items are better
than others like their sushi is like so
subpar and they do the seaweed on the
outside which I thought they only did
that grocery stores mm-hmm you know yeah
like I want rice on the outside I want
that texture so underrated that grocery
store sell sushi like when you're going
to Duane Reade
honestly it's not that bad they actually
moved it I don't know if they still do
it to what they tried to do like two
years ago but two years ago if you
walked into a random Duane Reade they
would have to see
it depends on the duane reade like some
of the newer ones that they're trying to
like modernize have fresh food and then
the old ones that are just drug stores
don't like who's gonna get their sushi
from Joyner and I'm sure it's fine if
you're just getting like you I would get
a sushi from Duane Reade that's just
like rice seaweed avocado and maybe fake
crab because that doesn't know bad um I
don't know if I would get salmon or tuna
mm-hmm
they should make feet crab but in white
where strings like you peel them out
yeah just like a piece of fake crab
that's not a bad idea
I think crab is delicious it is and it
doesn't go bad you take fake crab and
cheese to the bunker you're in business
you get a bad breath for months oh yeah
that's the other side of keto season
Brown for days it's just cheese cheese
ma'am no but it's also like when your
body's in ketosis like it forms acids in
your stomach that rise up three around
that are deadly mm-hmm so deadly that's
making it murderer that's a hilarious
hallmark movie Oh somebody dies like
they had their final kiss and like it's
dead I'll play I'll be in that reminds
me a bad breath Christmas anyways
welcome back to the show um I guess it's
only been like two or three weeks since
you were last here but it has been 24
hours since you did SoulCycle yes we
were talking about a little bit how was
your experience
first of all shout out to a Kanchan out
to SoulCycle they treated me very well
did they like today we roll out the red
carpet for you I actually they roll out
the red carpet for all first-time
writers no matter if you're blonde or
nobody well you say she didn't really
roll out the red carpet but I did show
up at 9:28 for a 9:30 SoulCycle
which I hear is like really bad really
bad they've released a bike I was gonna
say and they held my buy they brought me
in so like they did it was it was tough
it really hurt my ass like my ass
sitting here right now like still hurts
know it like and I like I said to them
if I come back I need a different
that's fair and Claudia said the same
thing I can tell you that the more that
you do it it becomes an obsolete issue
like I never have that problem now I
have different problems but not that
problem but you have to push past this
feeling of like did I take it up the
book last night yeah it was terrible
like that that part was terrible the
rest of it was just very interesting how
was the music the music was great
2011 house like perfect for me but
unbeknownst to you you went to the most
difficult social psych instructor in the
history of silicic yes but he's a legend
he's a legend and it was really fun the
class is so culty like hugs like I
didn't realize you know it's closer than
a toast it's really scary it's like it
like they're all just dancing to the
music in the same exact way and like
waving their toe and like like you would
think you were at a rave like I hate to
break it to you you're working out and
like I guess that's like part of the
thing it's like Oh Mike it's like like
have fun it's like Daybreaker yes but
like I don't like Daybreaker and I don't
need to be a part of a cult that like
pretends like they're having fun when
they're working out especially because
I've cracked the code which you all need
to know working out that's [ __ ]
nothing no but it releases endorphins
and endorphins make you happy and happy
people just don't shoot their husbands
they just oh sure sure and sometimes
wait if you're trying to lose weight
though what I find that working out does
for me it's like it's a mental thing
it's like I just feel good and you just
what you can't do and so many people do
it's like oh I burned a thousand
calories at soul cycle that means I only
consumed five hundred calories say it
like it doesn't work like that you don't
burn as many calories that total cycle
as you think you do so don't even
register those calories burn and you're
like you it doesn't mean you can eat
more eat the same amount eat whether
you're working out or not and you'll
just like feel better sure so I feel
better having that our back to sleep I
just oh I don't know why you would ever
go in the morning when why would I go at
night I go with 5:30 it's a good time
not all of us are so lucky no that's
true um but even when I was working a
nine-to-five I would be like out of
there at 4:45 like I have a doctor's
appointment at soul cycle she could move
but yeah soul cycle was so cycle was
fine now you're not gonna write it off
no but I was gonna wanna take you to my
musical Monday's class because it is
actually fun like I go for fun now like
last night I did told cycle and it was
hard work and I was like yeah she was
Treach yes so musical Monday's is fun
and I want to take you and if you don't
like it I'll never make you go down fine
I will come well I got your bike what I
must say though is that I understand now
there are no phones in SoulCycle
I just wanted to document my journey a
little because like it was hilarious
like people should know they know you
were filming like did I think I took
like one like little video where like I
showed not the class well he had just
showed where I was and I got yelled for
like a second but I give it by hacking
but it was fine because like he's like
then put away your phone and pet oh and
I'm like alright so I pedaled whatever
it wasn't like a put away your phone
you're in trouble it's like I know
you're not working out if you're filming
but then when I finished two things
happened one an old-ass lady came up
clean said I can told you to stop
filming so if you ever come back I
highly recommend you leave your phone in
your locker I'm like alright thanks lady
so much and then five minutes later I
checked my phone refreshing my DMS
because everybody it's a positive
encouragement I can't believe you went
to SoulCycle good for you hi there I
understand that you're famous on
Instagram I highly recommend the next
time that you go into a SoulCycle
not to distract you or others you should
put your phone away in your locker
kindly SoulCycle blank and I opened it
up and I'm thinking oh she works at the
New York place that I was just at yeah I
feel terrible this woman works in
Houston a SoulCycle in Houston Texas
messaged me saying that I was
distracting were you there was she there
I wasn't distracting at all i sat in the
back
I was high-fiving everyone everybody
like at the end of the Sprint they're
like high-five your partner look like
yeah and I got black from a woman in
Houston well I mean there's two things
here first of all they did to so many
people
no they you film the back of their heads
first of all like that was very ballsy
for you to film and it's always like oh
man I saw it I was like how did you even
do that
and the second thing is something that
you said that just that just stuck with
me and I'm gonna go into therapist mode
but you just said you
so many messages a positive
encouragement you're going to SoulCycle
good for you and then you've got one
negative message from a woman in Houston
saying don't film and like don't focus
on her no I know but like she's nuts
you shouldn't even see like I see
everything no but like don't focus on
that like there's so many positive
messages nobody knows of course the
positivity I understand I understand
anyways I'm proud of you for going I'm
shocked that as a born and bred New
Yorker that you've never gone and
someone who's like in touch with the
dieting world that you've never gotten
before I'm not an exercise class person
the only exercise things I've ever done
is like a personal trainer I got my jaw
closed ten packs and I tried two of them
and then I lead eight of them and then
it's just a waste of money and mm-hmm
had an equinox membership for three
years four years going twice those are
the types of things like to waste my
money on me right I've actually never
wasted my money on something like that
because I know myself well enough to
know and also my schedule is
unpredictable like I can't commit I
can't commit so you know wasting my
money I'm sure you feel this way too
because I haven't heard you go to any
Soho House property in quite some time I
got a message yesterday that I know
where I am I got a message
I guess journey that in 14 days my
membership fee will be processed oh yes
and I that reminded me that I haven't
been in three months okay that's funny
it is until it isn't it is until like
you need it or like you go and you have
a great time with a summer and you want
to go to the pool and there's no poles
in New York yes but also like the first
rule about up so houses don't talk about
so ha sorry I don't know sorry I don't
know because it's like I get in trouble
for taking pictures but then like I see
all of these surface monsters on my
Instagram like taking pictures on the
like videos on the roof and it's like
one did people not see it on their
Instagram and - did you not see them
taking the video I've literally seen
people taking pictures of me and so will
house and like I want to like tattletale
on them but I'm not that much of a
snitch yet but I'm getting to that point
like I have a draft in my email like
ready to go out - so House of all of the
people and screenshots that I've seen
this summer but I'm not there yet but
I'm getting there one more Cleveland day
I'm there it's much it's much crazier to
me that you would take out your phone at
so a house than me taking out my phone
it's all cycle like my phone I'm just
afraid
afraid because I just know no
tried-and-true rule for SoulCycle it's
just uh it's yes which I didn't even
know right so but no so house you
literally like if your phone is out
imagine I only appear me but imagine if
there was like a sniper on the roof they
see your phone dead no but not dead but
like they tranquilize you or did sure
like to need a charger card for eternity
but it's like have you seen that episode
of Sex in the City where Samantha can't
get into cell house but she finds the
other card Annabelle Bronstein I'm
Annabelle Bronstein that happened to
Olivia say what about Olivia someone
found it was the last name that they
used I don't know someone found Olivia's
membership card and was like keep going
to Soho House as Olivia for so long it's
so funny so she got Adamo Bronstein you
know so I remember the name then
honestly good for them the name that
Olivia's like the person that used
Olivia's card used was so funny I wish I
could remember the name did you remember
no but maybe Claudia will comment ok I'm
so funny they you guys deserve to know
you do it was really funny anyways
without further ado here are the fast
tech stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast unless I have no
season take a bite out of your morning
cucumber take a bite out of your morning
I do a handful of almonds that's good
the morning all the more maybe the
morning nut that's a great name that is
will do men's shells yes morning nut a
men's Kido show hosted by you morning
that there are a lot of good names for
men shows that we talked about but like
yeah but they're all like you know you
can't get sponsors I was gonna say even
if you just even if it's not sexual they
all just become sexual it's
unintentional what two things Claudia
said they changed her last name I'm
Olivia's account I don't know what they
changed it to Claudia please out of know
and Allie Mohajir who's like the number
one toaster goes hi I'm Olivia mahadji
I'm crying oh if only Olivia watched our
show totally what is she doing I don't
know like businesswoman's special Inc
she's having she's definitely out like a
breakfast mm-hmm
women in business at the Plaza looping
tee let's go
yeah totally are you in here
okay first story cardi B says baby
culture broke her vagina during
childbirth cardi B wishes someone warned
her about the aftermath of childbirth
quote she broke my vagina she announced
on Jimmy Kimmel Live on Wednesday why
nobody tells me about those things
nobody told me they were gonna stitch my
vagina people just be like oh you know
when you give birth it's gonna hurt but
no one tells you that like your vagina
it's even more surprising that no one
gave the eye like a trapper heads-up
considering how many people she had in
the delivery room with her she told host
Kimmel that her parents her
mother-in-law her husband offset her
sister and her publicist were all on
hand to welcome culture to the world in
July still despite the post labor pains
cardi said she wants three or four kids
quote I'm enjoying motherhood it's the
best it's like oh my gosh I should have
had you when I was a teenager she joked
this is what I've been missing my whole
life I love you that is so cute and so
true and if she watched morning tow she
would know that your vagina ribs from
front to back and you've got to get it
so nothing is that true damn yeah that
sounded like a mad lib like I don't know
like the the name culture it's a
beautiful name but like it like it it
sounded like you inserted like a random
word like where the name was supposed to
be totally like I was trying to like
what you were saying I didn't know the
baby's name was culture so I'm like oh
she gave birth to culture like Wow okay
it's so like I don't know
right like manifest yeah but I think
that's what she was like by meaning yeah
she's the mother of culture right and
honestly she is and her husband is the
father of culture offset amigos like
they are creating the culture totally
honest like they created culture and
they did and they did that's like naming
your baby like content like you have
created totally and yes like Co is pure
content oh my god premium content
gorgeous he's a model he's I mean I we
talked about Theo every day because I
always need an update on him but he is
just like a fine wine or cheese oh he
gets better oh my god absolutely most
cattle ears are about this big
I'd say there's they're the largest of
the toy dogs but he is like this big
he's lost so long he's like a he's like
a wild calves you know what I mean he's
a hot dog cast he's gorgeous oh he's
like looking good before telling good
he's acting so healthy good I'm Lloyd
yes no like that that's like us like I
mean like towards like his active life
like he now runs in Central Park for an
hour every morning no he's what I love
he's living a premium life we took him
to Bergdorf's the other day and he just
fit right in until his mom stepped on
his foot did he - did she tell you about
that it was very bad yeah it was tragic
Clawd gonna pick him up in him store
like no no no he was he was perfect like
and they went in there bring their dogs
and they like poked out of their bags
like it's a very dog friendly place and
there we went to the salon at Bergdorf's
and there was another dog there and Theo
was having the time of his life did she
step hard was he limping no no no no no
no let him decide it was it was a quick
it was like when you bang your elbow and
it's like oh my god but then it's over
I literally that sound that he makes
haunts me it's so sad
helpless helpless
Tigs I wanted you to breathe do today
but like I didn't know what kind of
thing I guess he's torture on the toes
and I'm wearing all black so I'm glad he
didn't mm-hmm shedding season shedding
season shedding for the wedding shedding
for the weather for the weddings you may
be may be shedding less these days I
don't know if he shed so much I think
shedding is also more of a seasonal
thing at least for me it is I shed more
as the seasons are changing I'm shedding
a lot actually I shed the most it's like
when I'm in the shower and I pull out so
much hair it's like I would be worried
but then like more girls it seems fine
yeah what's wrong right I didn't notice
anything I think I like one bald spot
but you know what nobody's perfect
nope no one um anyways thoughts go out
to cardi B in her vagine and yeah I feel
like all expectant mothers should know
that unless you have a c-section
your machine is destroyed is that that's
so crazy I know I mean it makes perfect
sense like I was always thinking how
does it just stretch and it doesn't it's
nice for you it rips it rips
my god what pain what pain oh yeah but
is it like can you choose to get a
c-section I think so I think there are
people who I think it's very I don't
want to insult if any of you have chosen
but it it's kind of like um a vain thing
to do it yeah mm-hmm you know but I
guess getting cut most up most people
get a c-section don't choose it it's
like no you're out now so they have to
and and honestly getting a c-section is
also a ton of tradition you get all your
organs removed and then place back in
mmm how crazy is that
but and you get a scar but your vagina
stays intact so it really is there's no
right way like there's no easy way
unless you have a surrogate oh my girl
and that's not easy either
but you know it hard work like you're
getting like the most precious gift of
all time and like of course good things
come to people who break their vagina
let's serve a jhanas Wow
that's an image you'll know soon yeah
that's an image or an I don't know how
soon does it say not too soon relax
people will see soon sure that's so
crazy okay so I posted a picture last
night with a most hilarious captioning
so I was wearing a liitle backpack and I
was like what is that a backpack for
ants no it's a backpack for ants a yes
and then a couple people were like who's
pregnant and I'm and I'm like wait do I
look really that pregnant this picture I
guess I'm from the side I look a little
pregnant I'm like that's kind of mean
especially because I looks naturally
it's a story like whatever and then I'm
realizing they think that someone else
is pregnant because I'm an ant but they
don't know that I'm gonna meet Justin Fu
sneetches really do they watch I don't
know I I was so confused so that means
that you if you have plenty of followers
that don't watch then you're doing
something right right I have a mixture
right so I guess I don't wanna not
everyone you know is fortunate enough to
watch the toast every day mm-hmm so no
but even if they watch it a person is
just insulted I was psyched you're
pregnant like wow way to like body shame
me no maybe the by the way why would
they be calling you pregnant if you're
an ant
I don't know when when they were like
who's pregnant I didn't put together the
ant part like got it so nobody knows all
I was seeing was pregnant baby on the
way back people have like baby I'm
I was like we that's like somebody
else's baby right it was it was
commodity yes per our president but it's
like they don't know about nephew
Sanitas and honestly I just feel sorry
for anyone who doesn't know about the
and nephew uncle snoot kisses of the
world mm-hmm and hopefully one day
cousins me chest em hmm the boy the boy
the man the myth next story Victoria
Beckham says she was the original easy
before there was easy there was Victoria
Beckham while Kanye West loves to brand
himself as an innovator taking credit
for opening the door for other musicians
to make their first forays into fashion
Beckham says she's the one responsible
for normalizing pop icons in the world
of Couture quote there was a way in the
industry of doing things the former
Spice Girl told Vogue Australia of her
runway debut in 2008 I knew there were
rules I had to abide by but I wanted to
be entrepreneurial and find different
ways of doing things Beckham continued I
was a pop star who turned into a fashion
designer and I didn't want to do things
the same way everyone else was doing
them and probably because I was a little
naive I wasn't scared to take on those
challenges in my own way she concluded
I've always said that this is not a
vanity project for me this is a business
I see her point if you have to say that
you are an icon than you are in an icon
no but she definitely like was I hadn't
thought about it but who was the first
like musician to do to be making clothes
but also like Kanye is the first
musician to be making clothes and music
at the same time maybe because she like
was a Spice Girl and then a fashion
designer she never like was a Spice Girl
and designer but who cares tomato
tomahto and like by the way both lines
are amazing but what you said before is
how I really feel about this story who
cares right and like what about Jessica
Simpson Simpson what about a [ __ ]
million people I think it's just oh I
guess I guess with what she's saying is
that it's now the norm and who pioneered
the norm
Conny saying that he pioneered the norm
for yeah but yet you're first also
there's a difference between being a
like a celebrity and having a clothing
brand and and having a like a creating
like a fashion house like I understand
her and Kanye are like Couture Jessica
Simpson is Kohl's sure
I wonder who's doing better monetarily
probably did since it makes so much
money actually I think Kanye makes the
most money because of like Adidas true
um but the bold is where it's at holds
Walmart a hundred percent yeah who else
says I doesn't Miley Cyrus have a line
more like everyone technically hasn't
like Selena Gomez had it like a clothing
line uh yeah you can just slap your name
on to anything if anybody who works at
Walmart wants to uh give us lines I
think we'll take a long I would totally
take a lining you know what I would
actually be like I wouldn't just put my
name on it unless you wanted me to I
could also be helpful so just let me
know I'll do anything very there
anything well we're really breezing
through the stories I mean that's what
happens when we just talk about
celebrity news and what's going on with
my keyboard and then we fill up three
more we do we did worker but also just
there wasn't that much going on today in
the slide world which is always nice
because it's been a crazy week Pete and
Arianna said how did you feel
also how did you feel that someone that
followed you just birkoff interrogate me
and Ariana are our close friends these
days have you gotten a lot of new
followers since youth all of you know
that doesn't happen anymore which is I
found shocking I thought I would get
like an influx yeah but no I have had
some nice steady growth though maybe it
has something to do with her I'm sure
the story was sad to me I was really
shocked look when when you have the kind
of [ __ ] that happened to Ariana with
Mack and all the stuff it probably is
very tough on peeps then becomes very
tough on the relationship and then I'm
sure that she didn't break up I mean we
don't we don't know anything but if I
had to guess she didn't break up with
him because she doesn't love him she
probably broke up with him because she's
going through a lot of stuff and wants
to be alone
unless you know like some deeper stuff
and me I mean I've been seeing some
things that like uh I guess when Mack
was still alive Pete was texting him
like intimate photos of Pete and Ariana
like to let him know like they're never
getting back together
and then when Mack passed away like
Mac's family told Ariana about that and
that's why she ended it that's what I
hear because oh so oh god that's sad
yeah it's really it's very sad and I
just I mean it doesn't shock me that the
relationship wasn't like the strongest
foundation and you know everlasting but
I'm just shocked that they like really
they threw in the towel so quickly after
making such a big stink about their
relationship totally you know that was
the shocking part it was like Tom and
LuAnn like getting divorced after six
months like I would have thought they
would have stayed together longer just
to prove a point
totally but I guess that's how bad it
was they couldn't even do that
mm-hmm okay next story missus seems to
be a trend but Kristen Bell is concerned
about the message snow white sends to
her children Kristen Bell may play a
disney princess but that doesn't mean
she's okay with the lessons they teach
her daughter's the 38 year old mother
revealed in a new interview with Parents
magazine that she's especially concerned
about some of the plot points in Snow
White
she told the outlet that she reads her
little ones every night who'd it's truly
my favorite part of the day and she
makes time to discuss in the book
afterwards quote every time we close to
no white I live I look at my girls and
ask don't you think it's weird that Snow
White didn't ask the old witch why she
needed to eat the apple or where she got
the Apple I say I would never take food
from a stranger with you and my kids are
like no and I'm like okay I'm doing
something right and then she also said
don't you think it's weird that the
prince kisses Snow White without her
permission because you could not kiss
someone if they're sleeping she says she
told them that also shared that reading
to her kids is incredibly important to
her because quote I look at my child's
brain like a hungry stomach I have to
feed it every day even if I'm rush I
have to feed their brain just like I
feed their belly well I have so much to
say I guess a story but I didn't know
this right and also a few days ago Keira
Knightley like made some comments one
about Kate Middleton and two about the
Little Mermaid how it sends a bad
message that she shouldn't have to lose
her voice for the man um
so two separate things but everyone like
loves who like look into Disney movies
and talk about like how they're [ __ ]
up like how Belle mostly got Stockholm
Syndrome from the Beast
um etcetera first of all Kristen Bell
like don't bite the hand that feeds you
like you are Anna from frozen like do we
not want to frozen - totally and
personally I love fairy tales and I love
Disney and like yes if you if you go
beneath the surface
like you know there's some problematic
themes but I really feel like in this
day and age Disney is modernizing like
in frozen the true love's kiss was from
her sister not from the man and in
Maleficent true love's kiss was from
Maleficent not from the prince yep so
we're making the positive changes that
we need to be absolutely all new movies
that come out are perfectly in tune with
what is necessary and and going on in in
the modern world if you look back at
every single old Disney movie as you
said there is something problematic with
it but you don't realize that as a child
like you just listen to it it's a fun
story whatever like these were these
were these are not meant for like old
ladies or not the Christian bells old
but like this is not meant for older
people to be reading and dissecting and
analyze and synthesize yeah exactly if
you want to go on like write a [ __ ]
paper then go to Harvard and watch all
the Disney movies and write your paper
and ruin it for the whole world but if
you want your daughter to watch Snow
White and think oh it's a fun Disney
princess movie believe me she's not
getting out of it that Snow White took
an apple from a stranger and that she's
supposed to like take things from
strangers that's not what you're
thinking about 18 years old it actually
is a positive message if you take an
apple from a stranger you will be
poisoned
totally there you go also like I feel
like especially as a child but me
personally and I remember in college
like some of my professors would say
this it's like I have a hard time like
going beneath the SIRT like analyzing
and synthesizing and did you sing I
really just read the surface I'm like
okay hey like William Shakespeare said
this he means this but they're like no
he really means this because but it's
like how do you know that no so also the
Prince didn't kiss somebody that was
asleep he kissed somebody that was in a
coma that if she wakes like the only way
she wakes up is with a kiss he did her a
favor do not kiss anybody if they're
sleeping and not in a coma and if your
kiss doesn't wake them up then that it's
wrong but if there's a big [ __ ] sign
that it's me and I'll wake up it's
called a favor
no one also like it's magic because that
wouldn't happen it no no man would be
like if I kiss her she'll wake up
because I true love's kiss unfortunately
isn't a real thing
totally but like as long as we're
pretending like Snow White is a real
thing everything that she said is not
true as you said the
Apple isn't fantastic lesson that if you
take anything from strangers you will
die
so never go home and you'll have to be
non-consensual II kiss yes totally that
is the message of Snow White um yeah
stop ruining children's movies they're
nice movies they are nice movies and
yeah like they're not any children's
movies for a reason like because
children are just like reading watching
it up here when you're like down there
yes if you want to be a weird adult that
died sex children's movies you can do
that they all they're all deeper than
they seem and Belle did not have
Stockholm Syndrome like the Beast was a
catch he was a cat she was so nice she
was so nice and he was so cute and like
as a be seen as mean like even cuter
than he was as a prince wearing makeup
by the way that's not that strange
people have problems with beating the
Beast yes they because he like kidnaps
her and then they think she has like
Stockholm Syndrome causing her to fall
in love with him even though he's like
her captor no no it's like a big story
no that's like PD an abuse is very
problematic for for some people but not
for me it's makes total sense for me
how strange even though the only part
that doesn't make sense is justice for
Gaston I have the most amazing idea and
I should probably stop talking about it
because I could implement it if I maybe
just stop
no because I won't because I'm not gonna
write a musical actually I could be an e
got but here's my idea because now I've
started but how wicked was like an
origin story for the Wicked Witch and
explained like how she got to be wicked
and became who she was they need to make
an origin story for Gaston to explain
like why like cuz he's a great guy but
he has like a little bit of like war
PTSD and you know he but he really like
just loved Belle and wanted to marry her
like so we need an origin story forgot
stone we're like justice served from him
for him and we can like see him in a new
light I'm not as hot I'm not as hot on
guest on is he or not he's kind of a
dick I mean but what why what makes him
tick what makes him dick he's just like
a like a big goof like I don't know it's
like a big manly
annoying pompous twelve dozen eggs
[ __ ] you know season trainer no he
sounds like someone I know
no he's like a modern-day sounds like
someone's
next to me please I don't mean 12 dozen
eggs you're not roughly the size of a
bar he's a great character I just don't
think he's uh I can do with you sorry I
was here she would say oh my god totally
let me swatch meeting the bees later to
remove it anyways I'm not here for the
coming of Disney films like no me
neither
leave well enough alone and it's not
like we're repeating the problem in this
day and age so you're a part of the
solution Kristen Bell with frozen so
just be proud of that
right make your kids watch frozen every
night or while we're talking about this
I could not be more excited for Aladdin
trailer oh my god I didn't see the
trailer oh I [ __ ] love and
live-action and Aladdin is probably my
favorite movie ever so oh really
it's my I think it's my favorite Disney
movie interesting I loved it loved
forever I'm trying to think about what
my favorite Disney movie is now it is
Beauty and the Beast 1,000% growing up
I'm not quite right you would think it
would be the Little Mermaid but I don't
know that I've ever see even seen that
little mermaid start to finish The
Little Mermaid is a good movie Aladdin
is a great movie really yeah I think
actually even growing up Beauty and the
Beast was my favorite because I remember
seeing it on Broadway I remember in
middle school Olivia starred as Belle in
our middle school production of Beauty
and the Beast and I was a town's person
and a supportive sister and I just loved
every minute of it
mm-hmm excellent even though the
townspeople are lera like not nice but
they were also according to some
theories stuck in a time work we can get
into that I understand Disney conspiracy
theories that actually be like an
interesting show there's so many Disney
conspiracy theories right like and how
all the Disney movies are entangled like
tangled and frozen the parents who died
in frozen were on their way to the
wedding of the people from tangled
there's like a lot of flow and yeah they
all kind of mix and match isn't that
nice
that is nice and I also loved Shrek I'm
done Chex Rex great yeah they better not
make a live-action Shrek I have a
question that would be [ __ ]
terrifying terrifying and by Fiona if
you need me
either princess or ogre
I don't mm-hmm I'm not too proud mm-hmm
um where's Mike Myers not being a thirst
monster and just like hanging out and
probably writing things you think so
really right he went from doing
everything you're doing nothing I'm like
worried about him and no one's like
where is he everyone forgot about him
like Austin Powers how much [ __ ]
money
that guy artist he's a comic like you
probably painting or writing behind the
scenes he was never like I mean like a
celebrity
no like he was a massive celebrity like
but like for a period of time for a
small period of time he was never like
show his face he was always like in
costume like Austin Powers or Shrek
Shrek or or the Love Guru I think that's
what did him in there he had a lot of
roles I'm just saying I think he's okay
for me like I always associated him with
like Adam Sandler and like Adam Sandler
is out here like making bad Netflix
movies I was a Myers yeah Adam Sandler
is destroying his legacy and Mike
Myers's pursuance Taylor is just raking
in money left right no huge he doesn't
care what yesterday but he doesn't need
any more money uh he was my literally my
favorite actor ever like Billy Madison
is the best literally the best movie
ever and he has just ever since
Spanglish it's just been a nosedive into
the ground you did enjoy Jack and Jill I
didn't enjoy anything
what about click all terrible these are
not like these are not funny movies no a
rom-com no he tried to like Steve Carell
his way out of the comedy we're all
terrible and it flopped and so he went
back to comedy but just doing even worse
things Chris cuz he'll pick up the check
awful which I respect he made so much
money from Netflix like I'm not upset
about that I'm upset about all the
movies that became before that did you
watch sandy wax Larson yeah [ __ ]
sister you watched it because I thought
turnout that we just watched a preview
and when we were in the Hamptons oh okay
maybe I didn't watch it Rica Claudia
they had this exact conversation I was
like oh I saw that she was like no we
just watched the commercial
okay well the commercial was terrible
and if it's a bad commercial then I'm
definitely not watching the show the
commercials supposed to be the best
parts of all of it totally the movie
yeah seems like I don't know much about
sandy backs like or Adam Sandler's
latest work or Mike Meyers
also um speaking of animated films I
don't know if you've been seeing my
emoji counselor snitch animated series
on the Instagram story but it has dawn
on me and everyone around me that I have
the voice for an animated character I'll
have to show you some of my original
work I'm working on a short animated
film about call of them the camp around
the counselor and loved it he's had me
really funny I've actually been told
that I have a nice voiceover voice as a
family we should make an animated film
I'd love to I think it would do really
well it could be called the speeches
sure what would you call it I don't know
I mean it would have to be like the
scenes like what else could you say to
describe us what would it be about the
speeches but we'd have to get the rights
from dr. Seuss but I feel like she'd be
down we could do it in collaboration I
know but it's fine because as like I'm
just glad there's a book out there
called the status that I'll be able to
read my kids to my kids one day and it's
like they're our star belly's nieces and
there are playing belly's nature says
and at the end we're all just sneezes I
love the message by the way if you want
to talk about dissecting something if
you dissect those dr. Seuss books
they're [ __ ] weird too yes like it I
guess yeah Mike Myers that was a great
movie that was a great movie but the
movie should like really highlighted how
weird the story is unbelievably weird
it's all weird but two kids it's not
weird no and kids are weird so they need
we are fun they're not they don't
there's always why they're not like
reading William Shakespeare yeah and if
they are they're even weirder though
that like young kid that like would come
up to you and say that like he just
finished like some 900 page sci-fi novel
like in the third grade no but like
sci-fi actually is fine like if you're
reading Harry Potter Lord of the Rings
whatever like sure but if you're reading
right that wasn't what I meant by sci-fi
those are like there was like standard
yeah that's like no change Hannah
Montana
absolutely I'm talking about like like
deep like airport books yes what's that
one Airport author Stephen King yeah oh
my god
there was a kid in my middle school that
read every single Stephen King book
in middle school that's weird I know but
also middle school isn't kids per se
okay elementary school is kids it was
kids yo middle school some people are
developing some people are getting their
periods other people aren't there yet
totally so if you're reading if you're
more mature that makes sense yep its own
11 make a wish Gucci bag Gucci bag Gucci
bag with your bag get your bag Gucci bag
boots baggage bags I'm always wishing
for a Gucci bag at 11:11 what do you
want before it's times up I want health
for everyone well we started wishing for
stuff like that but then I'd realize
like I try to make my wishes very
tangible so I can know if they came true
or not mmm like if I'm just wishing for
health and happiness like I don't know
if I'm happy okay I don't know if I'm
healthy so tough like you should have
had me prepare a wish what's it's still
oven 11 what's a tangible thing that you
want you want Maya Yankees tickets club
members Knicks I want Knicks
wood wood floor courtside all the time
all the time all the time okay that's
what I want okay okay good well I'm
gonna say it for you if you do if your
wish comes true just take me to one game
please of course well take you to 1212
last night was the Knicks opener I only
know that because the Empire State
Building was blue and orange so I
figured it was an important day for the
next and then melissa gorga posted it's
the next opener I was gonna say it
wasn't because I answer I'm sorry the
entire game no watch no I didn't because
I try to watch your stories with sound
because you just never know what's gonna
happen if there's a hair in it and I'm
sorry I wasn't no not yet I wasn't in a
position to watch myself the last one is
probably the funniest video ever I went
with my friend Ezra and we were going we
were leaving the knick game and you know
when you leave in a game there's a mad
rush down the escalators that by the way
whoever made it a rule that when you
leave a stadium they need to shut off
the escalators why does that happen
maybe if it's too many people it's a
safety hazard sure it's also more of a
vehicle they all fall they all fall
regardless so and also if you're gonna
have escalators that at one point are
gonna be stairs like please don't make
it so steep so steep so we got caught
behind an 85 year old woman and I asked
her if she wanted help she didn't want
me help so she's walking down the stairs
like I can't do it here but like
one step one step and I'm right behind
her and there is now a crowd of 200
people behind me and Ezra got to the
bottom and he is filming us it looks
like we're in slow motion walking down
the flight of ask like the escalators
with this old lady it's the funniest
video and you have to watch it well but
wait for her for not taking the elevator
getting herself in I don't even know bad
for Madison Square Garden by not marking
where an elevator is I don't know the
[ __ ] elevator is I'm sure she doesn't
either and she would've loved to have
taken it I think it in the elevator
actually it might be a service elevator
that's only for like backstage people
excuse me it's so many times me but yeah
I wasn't been at game last night Howard
Stern was there that was cool that's
cool
yes are you a fan of his work I'm just a
fan of like him being the Pioneer that
he is a completely I don't watch his
show but I respect the hell out of it
he's a pioneer Aaron judge was there it
was a camera standard yes I'm so glad
you get that yes is a star-studded event
that's cool and you were there yeah I I
felt pretty famous I'm not gonna lie
took a couple pics oh wait I heard Kelly
Bensimon was there according to the
toasters we know melissa gorga was there
on instagram Wow whooping what a big
night for New York it was celebs it was
lovely and the next one by 20 which is
shocking Wow yes I mean they played it
in my opinion what will go down is the
worst NBA team of all time which is the
Atlanta Hawks this year are really bad I
didn't even know that was a team yeah
they're really this year they're gonna
be really really really really bad okay
good to know if you play some bets mhm
um speaking of sports our next story is
sort of breaking news X USA Gymnastics
head indicted in Texas on a tampering
charge you guys this story is like
justice is served but the justice that
needed to be serviced just like so gross
Steve penny was handcuffed and shackled
before taking into custody on Wednesday
after being indicted by a grand jury in
Walker County Texas he was apprehended
in Gatlinburg Tennessee and
soon be extradited to Walker County
where the Carroll the ranch is located
penny allegedly ordered documents be
removed from the Carol Lee ranch in
Huntsville Texas that were related to
dr. Larry Nasser's disgraced doctor not
even dr. disgraced Larry Nasser's
activities at the training center that
impaired the investigation that was
being carried out by Texas Rangers who
were gathering evidence on NASA and his
enablers penny is now awaiting
extradition to Texas to face the
third-degree felony charge that is
punishable by two to 10 years in prison
if he's convicted he stepped down in
2017 to 2017 after 12 years with the
organization during which the young
athletes had the most success in the
program's history the u.s. women won
gold in the team all-around in 2012 and
2016 under penny with every single
member of those two teams having been
abused by Nasser okay so like not only
is Larry Nasser a monster but like the
these are the type of people that let
this stuff happen like not only did he
let it happen but he tampered with
evidence to help protect Larry Nasser
like I'm sorry there are other doctors
like it's not like oh my god we have a
doctor like we haven't protect him at
all cost
doctors are a dime a dozen no offense
and why would you protect this nasty
[ __ ] I'm so happy that justice
is served I hope he gets the maximum
sentence every time news about this
story comes out it makes me even angrier
also because just knowing how many
people covered up what Larry Nasser was
doing like it just makes me sick how
many discussing people like we're taking
advantage of and not protecting our
children and our most talented children
at that like Jim gymnasts are better
than everyone else like the amount of
work ethic their talent like is
incredible like they are better people
than we are yep and for them to not be
like protected and to be taken advantage
of and then lied to and have no one to
trust no authority to trust when they
all started out as children like it's
just such a violation and I hope
everyone goes down for it including like
all the people are like this is just the
tip of a spear there are so many people
at like Michigan who worked with our
Nasser who like knew and didn't do
anything and that's terrible you go away
to it's terrible the whole thing it's
terrible I think it we've spoken about
Larry now sir
we have and and now and I told my story
or now no I'm sorry about my
pediatrician oh I think you might have
Tourette's are you sure we do have a lot
of new listeners because we are
constantly growing so naturally as all
this is coming out me being the person
that I am selfish it hard but really I I
try and be a like a good person but like
I don't just think about like ooh what
is what has happened to me
and I started thinking you know I had a
I had a lovely upbringing
unbelievable parents unbelievable sister
unbelievable doctors but I have a
distinct memory of from the age of 8 to
16 I would go to the doctor I had a
lovely lady doctor when she was sick her
brother would come and I would go in
naturally I was it like went in just
like a young fat Jewish boy I would
always complained like try and get out
of school and my throat hurts like I
can't go to school for a week you know
like faking sick every day I had a
headache yeah
oh it must be in the water
I thought the nurse was on to me so like
when I one time I went and I was like I
have a headache like lol again she was
like then why is um whatever I would go
in and I'm like yeah I have a sore
throat and every single time okay then
remove your pants and he'd rub my nuts
or like grab them
sore throat nuts Wow
how do you feel I mean I'm not a doctor
so um I don't know whether or not a sore
throat is related to the morning nut but
that doesn't sound right
it sounds strange to me mm-hmm back to a
Larry Nasser though he's a scumbag and
everybody yes that if you hear even one
time that one kid said to one parent
that something [ __ ] up is going on in
there that's it that's it doesn't make
any sense that's why the whole story
doesn't make any time it's like not like
he's such an amazing doctor like it's it
makes it makes no sense the amount of
complaints against him and the amount of
time that it took it doesn't make any
sense and I completely agree with you
there have to be like hundreds of people
that need to be fired and by fired I
mean imprisoned no there needs to be
like hundreds
maybe a hundred people that need to go
to prison and then hundreds that need to
be fired also people are shook over your
story I guess they've just heard it so
many times I've already had my reaction
but um you need to call the cops and
also mom I'm not calling the cops didn't
do anything I'm fine make sure that he's
just not like practicing anymore
actually yeah but he sounds old he's
definitely not practicing oh could be
dead but it's just like weird thinking
about it but like it's fine I'm fine
yeah yeah it's just weird it's just a
little weird it's just a little bit but
it's also it's like a family joke I
don't know like like yeah man Miguel
like its throat hurt nuts nuts I guess
maybe it's not funny maybe not no but I
think it has to be funny
it's a destroy destroy me
yeah keep laughing man victim um that's
fine anyways I just love like when I get
a notification that justice is served
but then it reminds me of all the
terrible atrocities that are committed
in our world and what's even the point
you know then I just think what's the
point why bring children into this place
why rip open my vagina just so they can
hopefully avoid doctors like now Larry
Nasser and your old man mm-hmm not your
father your old man my old man by the
way can we talk about that for a second
who the hell calls their father old man
yeah my old man appeared go Timmy oh my
god rub some dirt in it oh good time so
back in the day before I met Zach and I
was just like living the life of Riley
third-wheeling bed and Claudia were just
like taking the town we went to Atlantic
City yes and we went to the club and I
happened to be wearing overalls which is
a weird twice and I took my shoes off
because they were uncomfortable and I'm
running around the bugs were strange
yeah but my logic city is strange yeah
it's not that weird room if I was doing
that at like Lavo it would not it would
not be okay send me send me away
mm-hmm running around the club and I
look like little Timmy well Timmy like
also I took your hat very good they were
giving away hat yes and they had one on
backwards you look like a young farm boy
so he called you little Timmy backwards
hat gene overalls
no shoes I looked like little Timmy and
it's like ah want to go out and play
that's great how was the original I'm
gonna go get some milk a little chili he
pitch me about a gallon of milk please
little Timmy was my alter ego her time
I'm no longer sometimes he emerges like
sometimes we'll be somewhere it's quite
like the like Timmy come out at the
State Fair
little Timmy did not come out at the
State Fair but he should have but he
could have if we weren't like trying to
be glamorous I understand actually
little Timmy came out at the end when I
was wearing this oversized Texas t-shirt
like my shoes were so thin flip-flops it
looks like I was wearing those shoes and
it started pouring rain and I was just
with a big piece of pizza
ah why is it raining do you think ouch
is the audio when I crack my knuckles I
hope so so that you hear at once and
stop doing it I just did it once like
Mike both of my hands cracked and I'm
wondering like an everybody cringing by
like hearing this sound well the other
night at dinner
snitch cracked all of her knuckles and
like I was surprised there weren't
fingers on her plate like it sounded
like she looks like a real cracker she's
a nut cracker she's every bone in her
body
yeah because she has like so many bones
and they just need to be like so true
she's like boom I don't have as many
bones as she does no she is like strong
bones yeah and they just gotta be
cracked gotta be cracked I mean she
works out so much like that's why I like
yeah she's got classes like yeah stay
crack again it's funny but if you work
out like it if you work out all the time
you have cracks do you never work out
you have cracks how do you get in the
middle where you have no cracks that's
me
you have no perhaps I'm no comment I
don't crack anything I cracked my back
before SoulCycle but that's a crack
everything literally if I move my arm it
cracks sometimes I crack my knuckles
like that listen you hear that I did
there's cracked my shoulder just by me
you want to hear some cracks I'm gonna
crack I'm gonna crack you up crazy did
you hear it nope oh my god I just got so
many hold on oh oh oh are you okay I'm
great no I do that all the time
that's the best way that's what I used
to do in school all the time but I guess
I'm never really in a chair now
see the crack yes oh now we're lying now
we can start show
now we're aligned umm fifth and final
story which is an interesting story and
sort of it's gonna lead me to another
story that we actually discussed you and
I almost half of us births happen
outside of marriage signaling a culture
shift reports Bloomberg births outside
of marriage have skyrocketed in
developed nations according to a report
from the United Nations Oh actually okay
so this makes more sense an increasing
number of births happen outside of
marriage signalling cultural and
economic shifts that are here to stay
according to a new report from the UN so
it's probably like not correct forty
percent of all births in the u.s. now
occur outside of wedlock up ten percent
from 1970 according to up from ten
percent in 1970 according to an annual
report released on Wednesday by the UN
Population Fund the largest
international provider of sexual and
reproductive health services that number
is even higher in the European Union
okay so what I was thinking was when we
you were last on the show we were saying
how the marriage rate is or no the
divorce rate is down yep because more
Millennials are getting married in
staying married but now also more people
are having children out of wedlock so
it's just like a lot of socia social
change yes behavioral change yes that's
just so interesting as you say after we
spoke about that I also read a different
stat which is that the divorce rate is
plummeting because nobody's getting
married so the people that are choosing
to get married are still are being are
more successful because so many West
people are getting married interesting I
didn't see that all I saw was that
people are just getting married later
maybe when they're more sure of their
choices sure or maybe they just like you
know don't wanna with us is the
exception of course we're like all just
getting hitched yeah for sure but I'm 25
like I'm an old [ __ ] that's a very
normal age to get married it is and I'll
be married at 26 that's very normal
that's later than I like would have
thought when I was five you know that
very no I'm gonna be married by 23 I'm
gonna have kids when I'm 25 can you
imagine if you just said kids right now
honestly I'm like getting there because
I really don't side from my bachelorette
party this weekend in like special
occasions
I'm not much of a drinker anymore so
like I could do no drinking nine months
I would love it but then it's like you
just have to take months off this show
no not really I would have to take like
a few I would want to probably take some
like post your loans but say I couldn't
for some reason like the schedule that
this show has like really would allow me
to be around around two hours around
alright that's the other around in
around the weight gain like I just don't
know that's really like so sad but
that's what's like freaking me out about
right these happens I know it changes
your face too depending on who you are
it depends some people that I just know
it's gonna change mine I'm gonna have
like gels mm-hmm yeah I'm just gonna get
that's true that's true I don't know
anyway so I just thought that was an
interesting little stat it is the world
is changing one's like so does that mean
that people are making a choice to have
a child like with somebody that there
are more just like I was gonna say or
just people like being like so
unbelievably irresponsible well I think
considering um you know because it
doesn't make sense
first there are so many birth control
options more than there's ever been you
know in the history because that's just
the nature of how medicine works like
there's just more um I feel like it
would be the accidental pregnancy rate
would be down Sam but so maybe it's just
more people who are just living modern
life lifestyles of you know we don't
need to get married but like I do want
to have children but they don't want to
save money I know they don't wanna get
on each other's insurance get on each
other's insurance and you just pay lower
taxes and like if you're met like if you
have a child together like I understand
not wanting to be married like you do
you I don't judge like two people can be
like raise raise a family and not be
married whatever you want to do but just
like from the way that our society
operates you save a lot of money if
you're married I'm like somebody
somebody call me out if I'm lying and
I'm making this up but I'm pretty sure
that you saved money that your taxes are
law
if you're married okay well and you file
together that's why chuck and Larry
pretended to be married
oh yeah something about the pension you
you there are advantages monetarily to
being married okay I'm positive
interesting I don't know what they are
and people are foregoing those just to
not get cannot be married it's very
interesting it is interesting it's just
interesting it's interesting I don't
know when how I know I don't know what
it means either it's just interesting
totally that's like do you here
yesterday Canada the whole country
legalized marijuana
thank God really Oh what are your
thoughts let people do whatever the [ __ ]
they want to do as long as it's not
hurting me
yes hurts me way more people smoking
cigarettes because the smell doesn't
leave and it's horrible
I think Claudia spoke about this on
Instagram so I don't know how much more
I can take about the neighbor and the
smoke and the whatever all that I'm
gonna say is that when the hall smells
like weed it's fine when the hole smells
like cigarettes
it makes me well like I live in a motel
yeah so it's just like I don't know I
love the legalization of weed especially
because I feel like it'll lead to less
people smoking cigarettes and I'd prefer
for you to be high than dead okay this
is not enough time in the day to smoke
cigarettes and weed when you go out for
your smoke break you're gonna pick what
do I want to know you're not gonna smoke
weed on your smoke break because like
that would be like drinking on the job
like no but I don't know so you're
saying that it's just gonna lead to more
smoking
I don't not less of a category it's
interesting it's I think it's apples and
oranges actually you do interesting um
okay now I'm gonna take some viewer
questions some of them are already asked
you about including ariana grande
SoulCycle yes please sing the lines you
wrote of your new song we heard that you
were writing a song oh I may bring them
down I don't remember
oh god well my phone is officially gone
okay I guess we got it later okay um I I
just think like I am a lyricist
I think up songs all the time and I was
gonna write one until it's funny that
she shared that I was writing a song
when she told me that it was
horrible idea but she she shared that
she told you that it was about 80 I
understand um and that she's writing a
song oh cool
so she's copying no no but that she was
doing it first and then you come what
song is she writing with some lies
it's called lies why well that's a great
name she is she is an unbelievable
singer and a horrible songwriter you
guys would really be a dynamic doo doo I
was like you heard her song and she's
hanging totally and like you guys could
be egads mm-hmm
it was honestly it was a slightly
depressing song is about a lost love hey
Wow
okay next question are you excited for
your two sister-in-laws weddings in one
year honestly no why too quick like two
together like weddings are it's not
yours look honestly I couldn't be do
they know when they are Livi and I are
getting married about two months apart a
month and a half actually no like can I
can I share the fact that Olivia's when
Olivia's getting married uh yes she
hiding it but yeah sure um she's getting
married on New Year's so sorry if I'm
like bursting that bubble for Olivia but
that I'm really excited about because
who the [ __ ] has New Year's plans
totally like now I have a plan so I get
[ __ ] up and we only leave the city and
we don't have to fly back home on
January 1st and we don't need to pay
like 9000 million dollars for a table
totally like just like if you want to go
to a club and have fun it's a million
dollars if you want to go anywhere in
New Year's is million dollars so I have
a fun thing to do I'm excited for your
wedding because it's just gonna be fun
but them together it's just like a lot
of I feel like it's a lot of joy it's a
lot of joy it's a lot it's a lot of
extended joy for sure but like for you
it's nothing but a good time you know ah
unless it's not unless there's something
I don't know I don't know I need to stay
on a like a strict diet for that period
sure but that's good like yeah and then
like also after my wedding then like
we'll be slowly coming into spring
summer and then you'll be in shape I
guess that's true like next spring I'm
gonna be like snatched it's true snatchy
oh it's not you go okay okay I'm excited
what are your thoughts on the new
apartment I love it
we got finally our couch came last night
we ordered from Z go
which is where your couch is from we
have the same cat it's a lovely couch
they need to work on their delivery
methods I'm not sure why they ship it
piece by piece like on a boat from China
that it takes four [ __ ] months for a
couch to be delivered that's insane to
me it has been four months three months
when did you go end of August we ordered
it
it's October September two months sorry
two months we got the stock colour it
was already in stock okay any Liana
furniture great if I had gotten the
custom color that is so funny that it
you've said for months but it's truly
like five weeks to two months to six
months six weeks too long
lol okay it should come in a week how is
Thea liking the couch he is liking it
he's jumping up on it so he's liking it
okay and he's breaking it in like he's
getting comfortable
yeah his scratch marks are on it already
Oh one's own do you feel like Westbrook
and George have a chance this year
no the Thunder stink
any team that I like I think speaking of
somebody that is pioneering fashion in
this world the same way that Kanye or
Victoria Beckham or whoever Simpson say
did that for the music world
Russell Westbrook has done that for the
sports world he is the most fashionable
player ever
that's and started a clothing company
and like he's killing it and he's an
unbelievable that a spell player but he
is proven not a great teammate and
nobody that ever plays on his team wins
so you're not doing anything this year
who asked that are they from Oklahoma
City I'll find out interesting ah no
they don't know Sadie I think they don't
have a chance at all no I think Sadie is
from Dallas actually um okay wait
this next question was um how does it
feel to have a wife who has a number one
web show in New York among Millennials
it feels fantastic call it's killing it
it's even crazier to me that she is a
touring comedian knowing her show in
Boston right yeah like that's that's
gonna be insane
what's crazy to me is that in a
six-month period it went from like me
making cameos on that show like I would
go up there and there'd be a QA and like
who's fun and funny whatever and now she
is if you haven't seen like her current
show she's a full stand-up comedian that
like is just on the level of other
stand-up comedians and like it's gonna
make it special like I know it and she's
gonna kill it and she's just killing it
totally
what are you answered this question
before but I want an updated version
there are new restaurants now what are
your favorite restaurants in the city
for someone who's going there and two
weeks in love some recommendations
there's only one restaurant to go to and
that is ishikawa I've mentioned it
before it's the best sushi restaurant
I've ever been to in my life it's on
74th between you're right so it's like
that's like so extreme like for someone
who's coming in New York like they want
to see the site and like not make a
reservation five months in advance and
pay a million dollars like it's not a
million dollars and you were it's worth
it if you can get a reservation get it
in general where to eat I don't know the
city honestly food like this do you love
any restaurants no I like it it's fine
it's fine
and the only thing I'd like love now and
I feel like I never even eat two things
I enjoy anymore totally just like Jurina
diet but I just like love good pasta
yeah it's good I actually just had a
great meal at Lavo it's funny that you
said bob was now around the oh no
actually I shouldn't should novels in
your hood it's in my head
it's in my head no that's so nice but I
had a lunch special there mm-hmm why did
you have $29 what was it what was in it
Caesar salad tuna tartare and a grilled
salmon yeah that's a great lunch special
that means nothing that it's not a
pricey lunch but like if you're gonna
splurge on a lunch a salad and appetizer
and an entree
it's like [ __ ] Applebee's but it's
not Applebee's it's Lavo but shout out
to Applebee's totally I used to go to
the B's all day I'll believe you okay
like just a great spot have you ever
been to the B's no I've never been go my
girl yeah oh good to know
also like Serafina is always a great
choice yeah it's just like
I went the other night it's drawn out
but to know the forks like I just can't
deal with like a smelly Fork
like I don't care what you're serving if
your fork is Mellie what are you doing
smelling your fork good when I put it up
to my mouth I like hey they're not that
their Forks were smelly was just giving
like smelly Fork vibes you know I think
there wasn't like a lot of like cuz the
problem wasn't the fork that smell it
was probably the food I'm not sure the
fork didn't even smell but like I just I
don't know they was like I don't know I
just wish they could give me plastic at
a restaurant
I have delicious pasta ever they just
moved to uptown I haven't been to the
uptown one and what it's like it's not
as good Oh actually I do have a place
that is unbelievable lorring place have
you been to luring place so so good
lorring place is incredible it's on I
think 8th maybe even fifth unbelievable
it's too far that's like so far so I
can't sit in traffic like yesterday was
the most Cleveland day of my life like
the traffic in the city and the starting
and the stopping of the uber and lyft
drivers it's just it's too much for me
to take the city and you know what
city's gone to [ __ ] instead of
complaining about it and like sitting in
the back of the car like the fact they
didn't throw up yesterday was a miracle
I'm just not going places anymore like
if I can't walk there I'm not going it's
it's become pretty unbearable to leave
the apartment or leave your apartment
between the hours of I'd say 8 & 7 8
a.m. to 7 p.m.
yeah Monday to Sunday cuz we went out
last night and getting around was fine
at night it's very easy yeah everybody's
off the road all those annoying it's all
commuters nobody lives here everybody
that is like causing problems on my
streets doesn't live here they're all
either uber drivers that live outside of
the borough or tourists that then go
back to their hotel at night they don't
know where I go all these people have
cars in the city like how rich are you I
don't know I don't know I don't know
it's all it's all over and left and
taxis is oh it's the streets you know
what they should do I'm gonna regret
saying this because I wouldn't want to
get in one necessarily like they should
just make much much much smaller
like go the the route of like Europe
with like those like smart cars should
just be taxis I know it's like terrible
to think about being in a smart car but
like wouldn't it solve some problems um
yes but then people would drive like
even crazier that's true maybe it's just
gonna bike Oh God I don't know no no
it's and clearly honestly if you get a
bike I hate you
maybe I'll get a razor scooter get an
electric scooter maybe I will actually
know anything that uses the bike lane I
hate because those are okay we need to
have our own show about city traffic we
should do a patreon episode yeah I was
on Madison Avenue the other day and do
you know so there's four lanes on
Madison Avenue I know two of them are
bus lanes and two of them are carly's do
you know that my like I actually never
appreciated
uber or until I started using lift and
like the thing about uber is like things
don't make sense and it's like annoying
and bah blah blah but like at least you
arrive somewhere alive like lyft it's
like if you will rival I've success five
stars
almost was murdered when I was in
Claudia we talked about on our patreon
episode and the other day I ordered a
lift I see it coming I check the license
plate I go to open the door cuz it stops
there's someone in there they hadn't
made their drop-off yet like they pass
me they kept driving too close that
makes no sense
wow that's so weird but do you know what
happened to me in my via two days ago
did you see my answer I'm sorry Wow my
three most premium Daisy I mean you
haven't seen my counselors snitching
emoji so we're fine but I've been I've
been really premium really premium
stories I was in the via which I love
these days like literally four dollars
and I can go anywhere I want do you ever
take to you I used to but right now for
like where like my travel patterns it
doesn't work for me I wish it did cuz
it's amazing it's amazing um except for
my experience the other day
anybody that takes via nose then you get
in the front seat because if you get in
the front seat
you don't next anybody you never have to
interact with anybody you don't have to
see anybody I get in the front seat of
my Mercedes mattress which by the way
why Mercedes like made like these weird
Toyota Sienna's I'll never understand I
did I get into the front of my Mercedes
mattress we're driving we're having a
nice time going downtown towards the
village den and OH
sudden we stopped to pick somebody up it
seems before the guy gets in the car he
opens up the trunk and puts a massive
massive massive box huge into the trunk
closes trunk and goes with the driver
and says oh I'm not getting in you're
just taking it to the address hopped out
got in the cab next to me he's I was
afraid of what could be in that [ __ ]
box of course a random man
DRI didn't he take it in his cab Porco
he was going somewhere else maybe no he
went oh sorry I hopped in a cab oh he
went back to his office or wherever he
was he was just using he was using a via
a ride-sharing app to transport a box if
you want to use an uber to do that
that's fine you do with your uber what
you want to do if you're a bird driver
agrees I don't put an unmarked box in
the car with three people that don't
know who you are
so weird and so [ __ ] was so scary like
it get a messenger if this box is that
important that's like one time I was in
an uber he was crazy I was in an uber
pool and I sat in the front and like the
couple behind me is like breathing
heavily and like things are crazy and he
couldn't drop me off where he was
supposed to drop me off he was like do
you mind if I drop you off here like I
have to take them to the hospital the
woman was in labor when they took an
uber pool you were in an uber pool with
a couple on their way to the hospital
because she was in labor what is wrong
with people urge splurge for the uber X
what's wrong with is that not crazy
crazy luckily I'm just an easygoing guy
and I was like okay I can walk that's so
crazy I also never understood people to
take uber pools together because of you
thinking whoever pulled together you're
paying double which is probably the
Charter the price of the uberx yeah it's
not like you just get an uber going well
like there are times where like I only
request pool and then there are times
when like I haven't ended in so long
which is like right now I've never been
pulled well I did I stopped you were
pulling when I started using via because
the via algorithm makes a lot more sense
than uber pulling via operates like a
bus like they don't go on side streets
they pick you up on the corner and they
top you off on a corner uber pool goes
on side streets and makes no goddamn
sense yes
shout-out to via except for allowing
that unmarked box in the car towed I
didn't hear of anybody that story I'm
hoping it was fine right anyways that's
our show
thank me there's no show tomorrow
because I'm on the way to the Bahamas
for my bachelorette party mm-hmm I'm
excited it's gonna be rowdy like any
Lancers no we're going to the SLS fun
yeah I'm so excited like I've seen such
premium content from there and everyone
like in the group chat is like so
[ __ ] fired up I'm like scared it's so
fun no it's like it's so fun everyone's
like sending gifs everything's all cat
that's the level right we're like an all
caps bunch wonderful I'm like nervous no
it'll be great I will know I'm nervous
for like how crazy it's going to be
total because you know it will be yeah
we're gonna hype it up it's too crazy
because then you could be let down
oh no but I'm also like I haven't
decided what my vibe is for the term I'm
just gonna feel it out of my ear Bob
needs to be crazy if it's granny you
know but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say
I have to be crazy and then they put
pressure on myself but usually when I go
on vacation I'm like by the pool like I
want drinks so well I'm gonna feel it
out and not putting any pressure if it's
here if it's here if it's here it's
gonna be exactly what I want and I'm
excited excellent so we will be back on
Tuesday we're taking a long weekend um
yeah we're coming back Monday so we'll
be back wow that's crazy
I mean it's Jackie oh no mo look well
while the toast is out for the next
couple of days you can tune into my
instrument for premium content okay you
should do like The Fast Five on yours
I'm sorry I'll do it for the next five
days okay well not you don't do it on
the weekends totally I'll do it Monday
I'll do Monday where can people follow
you at boy with no job at Big South
who's becoming really premium and about
to 25k congratulations thank you
speaking of premium ID Jackie oh
problems serving up she's you're serving
up premium stuff yeah become very
premium I really like you've been making
an effort for you guys and I know that
you appreciate it and that's all all I
need it's been very premium and I know
that I mentioned this last time because
I got a couple of a couple hundred
requests my podcast the schvitz
is right around the corner there is
nothing posted yet because the logo is
still in development but it is here it's
here so close I can taste I'm excited
it's at the shits so if you want to go
and follow it I will accept you and it's
currently private because there's
nothing there and the best thing long
awaited and
dissipation I wish I went private years
ago oh my god if I want private years
ago I'd be at 10 million if I wouldn't
have it yours yeah could be at a million
you could have been that's so sad to
think about I never happen not yet now
that I'm won't ever happen but I can now
it'll take so long yeah comment people
yet that's a whole nother it's another
story for another day for another show
for the morning nut before morning toast
some millennial Morning Show please
follow us on Facebook YouTube Instagram
make sure if you're watching on YouTube
to get comfortable while you're watching
on Facebook to get comfortable watching
on YouTube cuz soon we will be only on
YouTube because it is the most premium
of experiences and we will see you on
Tuesday have a great weekend everyone
bye
you